North Korea is spelling out a potential
battle plan against the United States
the regime says it will be ready to fire
four missiles toward wom later this
month the north korean general in charge
also mocked president trumps angry vow
to respond to new threats the general
called the president's fire and fury
warning a load of nonsense he went on to
say only absolute force can work on
someone as quote bereft of reason as
president Trump David Martin begins our
coverage at the Pentagon David good
morning good morning given North Korea's
rapid progress in developing nuclear
weapons it is no longer possible to
dismiss as mere bluster its threats to
attack American cities and military
bases and this latest threat from the
regime was very specific sometime in
mid-august North Korea says it's
planning to simultaneously launch four
Wysong twelve rockets they'll fly over
the islands of Japan and into the ocean
just 30 to 40 kilometers outside the
u.s. airbase on Guam other North Korean
state TV said the launch would be sent
as a warning pending approval from Kim
jong-un the threat came hours after US
defense secretary James Madison further
action by North Korea could lead to
quote the end of its regime and the
destruction of its people he spoke while
enroute to tour the USS Kentucky a
ballistic missile submarine which by
itself can carry 200 nuclear warheads
North Korea is estimated to have at most
several dozen nuclear weapon when 60
minutes one aboard the Kentucky last
summer the subs captain Brian Freck
described the destructive power at carry
the warheads that can be carried on my
missiles are extremely powerful and
compare them to the bomb that leveled
Hiroshima much more powerful than than
that up to 30 times more powerful and
the Kentucky is just one of several
ballistic missile submarines which on
any given day are hiding somewhere in
the world's oceans if this boat were a
country you'd be a nuclear power that's
true yes sir in a tweet yesterday
President Trump claimed he has updated
and modern
is the US nuclear arsenal saying it is
now far stronger and more powerful than
ever before there been no changes made
to the US nuclear arsenal on experts
like John Wolfe Stahl disputed the
president's claim that any changes have
occurred since he became commander in
chief some of the numbers have actually
gone down from where they were when
President Trump took office so I view
his statements is much more posturing
and trying to project strengthen with or
without improvements the Kentucky alone
can carry enough nuclear weapons to
annihilate North Korea there's no
question who would win a conflict
between the u.s. and North Korea the
question is can it be avoided Vlad
David Martin thank you very much